.
>> Dana: WE'LL BE WATCHING FOR
THE UPDATES.
THANK YOU, CHRISTINA.
>> I'M NOT A MEMBER OF THE GOOD
OLD BOYS CLUB SO I DON'T HAVE
107 SHERIFFS WHO WANT TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE BLACK PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS, WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO
GO WITHOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
I DON'T BELIEVE EVERY SHERIFF
WANTS THAT BUT I DO KNOW THAT WE
NEED A GOVERNOR WHO BELIEVES IN
BOTH DEFENDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT ALSO DEFENDING THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA.
>> Bill: THAT'S STACEY ABRAMS
MAKING WAVES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE.
NEWT GINGRICH REPRESENTED
GEORGIA.
KNOWS THE STATE AS WELL AS
ANYONE.
SHE INVOKED RACE CLEARLY IN THAT
ANSWER.
HOW DID YOU HEAR IT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, JUST FOR A
MOMENT PAUL PELOSI IN OUR
PRAYERS.
ALWAYS NICE TO US.
TERRIBLE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND I FEEL
COMPELLED FOLLOWING THAT REPORT
TO JUST SAY WE SHOULD ALL KEEP
PAUL IN OUR PRAYERS AND HOPE HE
RECOVERS FULLY.
LOOK, STACEY ABRAMS -- I TWEETED
ABOUT THIS.
I'M WORKING ON A PAPER ABOUT THE
TWO WINGS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THE WEIRD WING AND THE INSANE
WING.
SHE IS CLEARLY IN THE INSANE
DOES ANYBODY REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE SHERIFFS WHO GET UP
EVERY MORNING HOPING TO ARREST
BLACKS AND TAKE THEM OFF THE
STREET?
IT IS A WILD HALLUCINATION.
IT TELLS YOU ABOUT THIS
ALTERNATIVE UNIVERSE THAT STACEY
ABRAMS LIVES IN THAT HAS NO
RELATIONSHIP TO THE REAL WORLD.
AND SO SAYING SHE HAD NEVER BEEN
DEFEATED.
THE SAME UNIVERSE TO SAY THEY
SHOULD MOVE THE ALL-STAR GAME
AWAY FROM ATLANTA, WHICH HURT
MINORITY-OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES
AND MAY HAVE COST $1 HUNDRED
MILLION TO SMALL BUSINESSES IN
ATLANTA.
SO THIS IS SORT OF TYPICAL.
AS THE LEFT DISINTEGRATES YOU
SEE THEM GETTING WILDER AND
WILDER IN THEIR COMMENTS.
YOU HAVE THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK CLAIMING THAT THE RED
STATES HAVE WORSE CRIME THAN THE
BLUE STATES, WHICH IS JUST PLAIN
FACTUALLY FALSE.
THE KIND OF STUFF THEY CAN'T
TELL THE TRUTH, THEY CAN'T
CAMPAIGN ON THE ISSUES AND THEY
DON'T HAVE MUCH LEFT.
>> Bill: LET ME PLAY A CLIP OF
THIS.
CRIME IS AN ISSUE FOR A LOT OF
VOTERS.
IT IS SHOWING UP IN ALL THE
POLLING.
HERE IS KATHY HOCHUL ON SUNDAY
ON CBS TALKING ABOUT CRIME.
>> THESE ARE MASTER
MANIPULATORS, THEY HAVE THIS
CONSPIRACY GOING ALL ACROSS
AMERICA TO TRY TO CONVINCE
PEOPLE THAT IN DEMOCRATIC STATES
THEY'RE NOT AS SAFE.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE ALSO NOT ONLY ELECTION
DENIERS.
THE SAFER PLACES ARE THE
DEMOCRATIC STATES.
>> Bill: THAT WAS MSNBC FROM
OVER THE WEEKEND.
LEE ZELDIN TOLD DANA AND ME
YESTERDAY -- NEW YORK CITY AND
THE -- HE NEEDS AT LEAST 30% IN
NEW YORK CITY TO HAVE A SHOT AT
WINNING.
THE NUMBER HE DROPPED YESTERDAY
WAS 35.
THE BASELINE TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT HE CAN WIN STATEWIDE.
THE OBVIOUS INDICATOR THERE FOR
PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME.
THIS IS A HARD STATE TO WIN
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN DEEP, DEEP
BLUE.
>> OH YEAH.
LOOK.
IF ZELDIN WINS, I THINK HE WILL,
THAT IS AN AMAZING SIGN OF HOW
BIG THE TSUNAMI IS GOING TO BE
ACROSS THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA AND
ILLINOIS ARE ALL THREE VERY
TOUGH STATES.
TWO OF THEM HAVE CLOSE GOVERNORS
RACES, ILLINOIS WHERE THE
GOVERNOR HAS SIGNED -- AGAIN, AN
INSANELY SOUGHT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY BILL TO CREATE NO BAIL
AND PUT CRIMINALS BACK ON THE
STREET EVEN THOUGH VIRTUALLY
EVERY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
EVERY SHERIFF AND EVERY POLICE
CHIEF HAS OPPOSED IT.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
LEARN ANYTHING.
NEW YORK CITY THE QUESTION IS
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE TO DIE IN
THE SUBWAYS, HOW MANY CARS HAVE
TO BE CARJACKED, HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE TO BE RANDOMLY SHOT FOR IT
TO MATTER?
THE GOVERNOR HAS ALL THESE
COMMENTS ON SUNDAY.
LOOK AT THE SHOOTINGS AND THE
MURDERS IN CHICAGO THIS WEEKEND
ALONE.
I THINK IT WAS A 3-YEAR-OLD A
14-YEAR-OLD AND AN 11-YEAR-OLD
WERE SHOT THIS WEEKEND IN
CHICAGO.
NOW, IF YOU ARE A NORMAL,
RATIONAL PERSON YOU KNOW THAT
THE CITIES RUN BY DEMOCRATS ARE
THE MOST DANGEROUS CITIES IN
AMERICA.
THAT'S JUST A FACT.
AND WE WERE JUST IN MINNEAPOLIS.
DOWNTOWN MINNEAPOLIS IS A
DISASTER BECAUSE AGAIN THE
ANTI-POLICE LEFT DON'T WANT TO
LOCK ANYBODY OFF AND THEY ARE
SHOCKED CRIME GOES UP.
>> Bill: MAYBE WE'LL SEE IT ON
TUESDAY NIGHT MAYBE NOT JUST IN
THE PLACES YOU MENTIONED AND
MAYBE IN WISCONSIN AS WE